[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravie de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui dans ce nouveau
numéro du skycho le magazine qui raconte
toutes les aventures économiques du
territoire de saintant an Yvin pour
cette nouvelle édition consacrée à
l'enseignement supérieur nous irons à la
rencontre de Alain bu qui est le
président de l'université de Versailles
saanttin ivin nous parlerons avec lui du
lancement notamment de l'Académie
spatiale mais aussi de l'intégration
pleine et enti ch de l'université
d'evvry et de Versailles 550 an NG comme
d'habitude nous y reviendrons un peu
plus en détail dans ce numéro mais tout
de suite voici le sommaire le 20 janvier
dernier se tenait le salon de l'étudiant
au Vélodrome de saint-quanttin en
Yveline alors que les lycéens ont
jusqu'au 14 mars pour formuler leur V
parcours sup le salon était l'occasion
de découvrir les nombreuses écoles du
territoire dès le 1er janvier 2025
l'université d'evvr et de Versailles 5
an en yine vont entièrement être intégré
dans ce numéro nous irons à la rencontre
d'Alain Bui président de l'université
versaill saquanttin yeline pour
comprendre l'enjeu de ce partenariat en
collaboration avec le territoire de
c-tin en Yveline l'école 3IS produit des
vidéos pour mettre en avant les écoles
du territoire Enzo boisan ancien
étudiant de 3IS nous en dit plus sur ce
projet dont il fait
[Musique]
partie commerce ingénierie ou encore
agriculture choisir son orientation est
souvent synonyme de stress alors pour
accompagner les lycéens le salon de
l'étudiant a fait son grand retour au
Vélodrome de Saint-Quentin en yeline
après l'ouverture de parcours suple le
17 janvier dernier étudiants et parents
étaient nombreux à venir découvrir les
formations le salon principalement
permet aux étudiants et leurs parents de
s'informer d'être en contact direct avec
les écoles et donc du coup de pouvoir
avoir les conseils et d'être le mieux
aiguillé pour donc faire leur vœux par
la suite et choisir leur formation
postbac parmi les 70 exposants 40
établissements de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline c'est le cas de l'école
supérieure des agricultures de guyencour
dont les formations attirent les
étudiants ce qui est bien c'est qu'on a
deux autres cycles qui sont moins
rapides Bachelor ça va être 3 ans alors
ce sera il y aura toujours du concret
mais il y aura un peu plus de théorique
cette fois-ci ça reste des métiers assez
importants c'est quand même la base de
la survie d'une société l'agriculture on
en a tous besoin et surtout dans le
contexte actuel contexte économique euh
et surtout le contexte environnemental
s'il y a bien un truc que j'ai remarqué
au au sein de la jeunesse en tout cas
des gens de mon âge à peu près c'est
qu'il y a un engouement qui se crée plus
ou moins autour du côté environnemental
et pour ceux qui se tourneraient vers le
public une université celle de
Versailles SaintQuentin en Yveline
membre de Paris saclé on est quand même
la seule université présente ici les
autres c'est des écoles privé plus ou
moins donc on représente un peu le
secteur public aussi une diversité de
formation qui a attiré plus de 4000
étudiants étaient présents cette année
je suis déjà venue il y a 2 ans et oui
en vrai on retrouve assez d'information
et bah il y a beaucoup de volontaires
qui répondent à nos à nos questions des
réponses auxquelles il faudra répondre
avant le le 14 mars pour les formations
publiques date de clôture de formulation
des vœux sur parcours
[Musique]
sup d'ici 2025 l'université d'evv et de
Versailles saint-quenttin en Eveline
devrait s'intégrer pleinement pour en
parler je suis aujourd'hui avec le
président de l'université de Versailles
SaintQuentin en Yveline Alain buit
bonjour bonjour alors pour mieux
comprendre ce partenariat est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer d'abord à
quoi ça correspond concrètement alors
2024 est une étape importante ça va être
le l'année de la finalisation du projet
Paris
Saclay pour laquelle
l'UVSQ depuis les début les balbuements
de ce projet qui est membre fondateur de
de cette université et donc ce que vous
appelez l'intégration pleine et entière
pour peut-être pour que ça soit clair
pour pour tout le monde c'est la
finalisation de plusieurs années de de
projet et avec une une université de
versaill 550 enine qui va se transformer
et peut-être pour l'expliquer de la
manière la plus simple c'est que
l'université de versaill 50 va devenir
va changer de nom et va devenir
Université Paris saclcly TR Versailles
tous les campus de l'UVSQ aujourd'hui
vont de manière définitive devenir des
campus de cette de ce projet d'envergure
de de l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche qui est l'Université Paris
SACL pourquoi vous avez décidé de de
mettre ça en place de changer de nom
alors c'est pour traduire simplement
cette forme d'intégration plané enire
cette forme de fusion c'est-à-dire que
tout ce qui va concerner le cœur de
métier de l'Université des universités
qui est la la formation et la recherche
et bien tout ça va correspondre à cet
ensemble de SEP établissements donc qui
sont trois universités l'université
d'evvr et Versailles saint-quanttinville
mais aussi l'université expis sud et
puis quatre grandes écoles d'ingénieur
pour en former une université qui qu'on
appelle intensive de recherche et mais
qui se traduit aussi de partir des
territoires pour s'ouvrir vers
l'international c'est un projet qui
s'inscrit dans un projet national
c'està-dire de regroupement
d'universités et d'écoles dans pour
faire des universités d'une d'une taille
d'une quelque part d'assez puissante
pour être visible au niveau
international d'avoir une envergure
internationale et nous nous avons la
chance dans le territoire des Iline
d'avoir une d'être symbolisé par la
Ville de Versailles qui est l'une des
rares villes qui est aussi une marque
mondiale avec Paris et Bordeaux et donc
d'attirer aussi des étudiants des
chercheurs intern nationaux et de
pouvoir poursuivre notre développement
qu'est-ce qui va changer pour l'UVSQ
donc à part changer de nom est-ce qu'il
y a des choses qui vont changer pour les
étudiants par exemple bien à la fois oui
et non non parce que en fait les
diplômes sont déjà des diplômes communs
on va renforcer ça c'està-dire
qu'aujourd'hui de la licence jusqu'au
doctorat en passant par les masters
seront tous diplômés ont tous exactement
le même diplôme le même niveau de
diplôme comme c'est déjà quasiment vrai
depuis plusieurs années en fait on met
en commun nos forces nos diplômes nos
forces de recherche nos laboratoires nos
partenariats avec avec le tissu
socio-économique tout ça en commun pour
avoir une une université de rang
mondiale mais je tiens aussi à préciser
que l'UVSQ garde aussi quelque part ses
spécificités territoriales euh avec ces
domaines d'excellence qu'il viennent
apporter au projet si tout se passe bien
à la fin
2024 au plus tard au début 2025 euh nous
aurons euh cette université euh pleine
Université Paris SAÉ donc qui va être
complètement finalisée et la
transformation donc du nom de notre
université je le disais aussi en début
d'émission euh vous avez vous allez
mettre en place une académie spatiale
alors ça veut dire quoi en fait académie
spatiale qu'est-ce que vous allez
proposer aux étudiants c'est quoi le le
projet de l'Académie spatiale alors pour
le comprendre c'est justement euh euh
c'est un projet de l'Université Paris
saclin dans son ensemble et c'est aussi
un des domaine phare de de l'UVSQ c'est
un projet qui est financé par France
2030 projet d'investissement d'avenir et
qui comprend l'Université Paris saclé
donc évidemment l'UVSQ mais également
l'Université Sorbonne Université Paris
Cité donc université
d'île-de-fance avec des partenaires
privés dans le domaine de l'espace comme
Thalès comme Arian et cetera et donc ce
projet c'est le but de former des les
cadres de main techniciens et cadres de
main autour
du domaine du spatial pour toute l'île
de- France donc c'est un projet très
important très important pour pour le
développement du spatial au sein de la
France et en île-de-fance on est donc un
acteur majeur à travers l'Université
Paris saint-clai pour porter cette
académie ça va regrouper tout ce qui
existe autour du spatial donc je vous
prendre peut-être l'exemple à travers
l'vsq mais a décliner sur l'ensemble de
nos partenaire l'UVSQ à travers le
laboratoire l'Atmos qui est AG guuill en
cour et un laboratoire phare sur le
domaine du spatiel l'obtion de la Terre
depuis longtemps alors je ne sais pas si
si tous nos téléspectateurs le savent
mais quand vous entendez parler de la
mission persévérance du rover
persévérance sur Mars projet en
collaboration avec la NASA ou de la
sonde
Roseta l'UVSQ à travers le laboratoire
l'Atmos participe depuis longtemps à ce
type de d'événements majeurs importants
à travers des instruments qu'il
développe et puis plus récemment nous
avons
développé une filière 100 %
universitaire à travers des
nanosatellites et puis ce qu'on appelle
le
newpace où on a construit un tout petit
satellite vous voyez sur laaffiche
derrière mais un tout petit satellite et
qu'on a développé avec les étudiants
donc à partir de avec des étudiants avec
des chercheurs et après qu'on a lancé
donc on est en deuxème lancement à
travers le lanceur SpaceX ouais et donc
le le but de de ce de ce projet de C
Acadie spatiale c'est de valoriser et de
poursuivre le développement de ce type
de filière qui vont des petits au gros
projets dans l'espace et de tous les
métiers que l'on peut offrir autour le
spatial c'est aussi de l'ingénierie
c'est aussi de l'innovation donc vous
avez tout ce type de métier de ce
formation qu'on peut offrir à travers à
travers toute l'îlede-fance ouis c'est
déjà lancé cette académie quand est-ce
qu'elle va se concrétiser ou est-ce que
il y a quelque chose se lance maintenant
donc on a elle c'est elle est en train
de se se mettre en place actuellement
çaen est vraiment au début et combien de
personnes devraient participer à cette
académie spatiale vous avez un nombre ou
il y a un quotat comment ça se passe euh
c'est difficile à dire donc ça vous avez
un ensemble de laboratoire donc vous
avez en en terme d'acteur évidemment
plusieurs centaines de personnes après
le projet va nous permettre de recruter
des gens de développer des filières et
donc tout ça je pense que je vous donne
rendez-vous peut-être d'ici un an pour
vous en parler un peu plus précisément
et bien merci alors le rendez-vous est
pris donc l'année prochaine et nous on
continue ce numéro avec l'interview
express de Enzo boigan qui est ancien
étudiant de 3IS à propos des vidéos
réalisées en collaboration avec le
territoire de C50 an
[Musique]
yeline on produit des vidéos avec le
territoire de 50 Anin plus précisément
avec le service école supérieur les
relations avec les écoles supérieures
sur tout le territoire de 550 an en
iveline et le but de cette vidéo c'est
tout simpleement bah de montrer de
présenter ces écoles de montrer leurs
engagements leurs valeurs et également
bah leur place et leur implantation au
sein de 50 ans c'est des vidéos d'une
minute 30 c'est du contenu hyper rapide
très informatif dans lequel on va voir
une personne qui représente l'école
plutôt l'administration et on va voir
également un point de vue étudiant qui
va voilà parler de la vie étudiante sur
son
campus cy en fait ça fait 36 ans que
c'est implanté sur le territoire de
saintant livin on est la seule école de
du territoire avec un campus plutôt
important tout simplement l'idée de ce
partenariat elle est venue du Service
Relation école supérieure de 50 Evelin
qui nous a approché en tant qu'école
d'audiovisuelle et qui voulait tout
simplement mettre en valeur l'ensemble
des écoles sur le territoire de 50 ans
[Musique]
Enel pour l'instant il y a peu près un
peu plus d'une dizaine de vidéos qui
sont prévues et l'objectif c'est de
couvrir tout le maillage des écoles
supérieures qu'il y a sur le
territoire je suis très content en tant
qu'étudiant de 3IS de travailler sur ce
partenariat parce que ça permet d'être
tout de suite impliqué dans la vie
professionnelle c'est vraiment un des
objectifs de 3IS et c'est encore un
nouveau partenariat qu'on qu'on ajoute à
notre liste ça fait des années que sur
le territoire de saeline on travaille
vraiment en collaboration donc oui en
effet je pense qu'il y aura encore plein
de projets qui nous attendent et qui
attendent bah tous nos étudiants donc ça
risque d'être assez rempli pour 3IS dans
les prochaines
[Musique]
années
on termine avec l'agenda ce mois-ci ne
manquez pas entreprise faites vos jeux à
l'au des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 le ski cube vous
propose une série de Serious Game chaque
mois de février à septembre venez
développer vos compétences et booster
votre activité premier rendez-vous le
1er février prochain l'atelier entretien
d'embauche les bonnes habitudes pour
réussir le 1er février à 9h30 le skiq
vous propose un atelier pratico pratique
pour savoir mener un entretien
d'embauche au programme exercice
pratique et training en situation réelle
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur
[Musique]
tv78